qu'est ce qui vous a permis de passer à
cette étape du projet collectif dans le
parcours académie des dalons ce qui m'a
permis de passer les étapes du projet
collectif
c'est les programmes pédagogiques très
intense et les développements
dès mes compétences qu'est ce que le
projet collectif le projet collectif
c'est quelque chose qu'on doit mettre en
place pendant les trois mois avec un
portage un échange de connaissances
qu'elle était le projet de chaque
équipage de l'équipage eu une journée
avec les personnes à mobilité réduite
équipage dieu
une journée de sensibilisation suit
ainsi polluer et l'équipage 3 qui
mouvoir l'île de la réunion avec les
lieux comment en êtes vous arrivé à ce
projet et avec quels moyens
donna les trois équipages nous
rassembler
le projet et ça a admis un clip vidéo
sur
les dangers de la route je veux c'est
une chanson comment avez vous fait pour
réaliser le texte déjà commencé à
mobiliser de gros
un bon scénario un bonne écriture et
toutes les dalles aux compétiteurs là
pourquoi décidez la mecque tout-en-un
mais comme tu es mon café de son rapport
le texte des bulles d'un monsieur il
faut tenter la rue est à nous et là
millions performant comment avez vous
adapté le texte avec les intervenants
des z'arts bande à montanou comment
j'allais chanter chacun avait son époux
chanter la séquence est n'avait veulent
voir grave si nos bonnes voitures donc
l'adapter la télé comme auchan t bonds
us après sept ans le texte j'ai passé
les talons même avec nos débuts au
volant il dit bois l'alcool des fantômes
et au fme restons case la rue n'est pas
un terrain de jeu commence et j'ai dû
passer ce message
les routiers et atos aussi la route
parce que notre union of thé ou l'autre
des deux joueurs jours magath salengro
tristesse commémoraient ce n'est pas
normal
vous n'êtes pas conscience et il met les
faits une coutu pas quand les équipes et
d'ouvrir l'art une peinture injures
temine partout et s'il ne marque pas
déconner j'ai tout va comme on frotte au
volant ou les pâtes bons ballons aux
alentours
j'ai mal partout ici il ne manque pas
déconner j'ai tout cas comme un fantôme
où l'on n'oublie pas tous bons ballons
aux alentours bonpé la finance et des
banques a fini à valley 3 - tout ça l'a
été par un stop sourit gilles véridique
à militer pour le bal routier quand même
et les faits il fait l'accident pour
rien voilà ça va montage d un texte
comme ça va maintenant
en différence il était un bon moment il
a mérité ce paie même pas eu des
batailles il était à bonal honte au
japon l'a fait à militer casse le rouge
de montech chamaille on y voit la
dissidente poteau ce portail sont madame
x maï maï ce moment sur pamiers va
toujours pas sally ireland allô allô ici
béton la mode alors d'en bas ce monde
avait déjà commencé et un beau salut les
amis savaient manier le penser nous
allons décider
il était comme mon frère depuis lors le
meilleur
il était comme mon frère pour ça même
mon fils il apprend le violon un virage
de tournon l'alcool de leçons d'un mois
que plus de bombes n'étaient bons
moments il avait été sérieusement on
n'était pas assez mais les rescapés à
ces handicapés parce qu'ils aient
également viguier ne voulait pas facile
dit que la ville dans les tirs
il est trop tard pour faire on aurait dû
pont sli oc fait la morale on va juste
tribunal il vous prend comme le sont les
dépanne ballon à mal d'alcool acteurs
apathiques et bruno bourgeon et aux
produits stupéfiants d'internet tout le
temps c'est quand le concerné que vous
lisiez pas les bouffer pour le partage
des voix on a comparé les voir de
trouver dans l'eau on a vu que les
dalots avait certes un dalot avait une
voix et les aigus que donne et d'autres
effets plus graves dont qu en fonction
de ça on a pu partager les voir quels
étaient vos difficultés des commandes
ma difficulté le champ et avec la
contribution de charles dans l'eau j'ai
pu m'en sortir et pouvoir compter moins
de vous procédé pour décrire les
scénarios pour scénario on a séparé les
d'allouer des équipes une équipe sur
l'écriture du scénario et une équipe sur
l'écriture du texte
donc on avait une première idée de
scénario ce qu'on n'avait pas le temps
ni les moyens techniques un
professionnel de l'audiovisuel qui nous
a aidés à adapter scénarios en fonction
de nos moyens et du temps qu'on avait et
à mettre tout ça on avait une première
idée de scénario c'était de mettre en
scène un jeune qui sortait de boîte et
qui rentrent en collision avec un
automobiliste matelas sur lequel on
s'est dit que cette idée c'était à peu
quitté ja vu pourquoi avez vous choisi
le rôle des jeunes accidentés
je me suis porté volontaire pour la
sensibiliser le public on les accidents
de la route
parce que ça peut arriver à n'importe
qui n'importe quand et pas que les agit
la route prennent conscience du risque
qu'il ya à chaque joueur quel mode
d'expression avez vous utilisé y
pourquoi on a écrit cela m'a valu
messieurs willi fontaine les dalots pour
sensibiliser les gens sur la route et
les accidents et les morts etc pour
prendre conscience les jeunes il faut
arrêter de faire n'importe quoi c'est la
route
comment s'est passée les réflexions
balle à répétition sont
son bien c'est un espace et les dahalo
sont ils ont bien révisé et tout donc
voilà comment ils ont fait pour préparer
le studio ben le studio on a préparé
avec l'un des chambres des dalots n'a
pris des tapis de sol des matelas voilà
on a mis contre le mur et pour isoler la
chambre comme ça on peut faire du studio
comment s'est passé l'enregistrement
peut justement jazz le tango c'est une
fierté pour moi de te relire le
professionnel non justement
on voit même une tornade le danois ans
du couple douteuses que pouvoir que le
buzz
comment avez vous fait pour réaliser le
clip vidéo alors une fois que le
scénario a été écrit et validé nous
avons contacté les différents
partenaires nous avons sollicité pour le
prix d'un calmant dépannage d'une
voiture accidentée
un drame en tueur un corbillard à
l'équipe de monsieur louis fontaine qui
t'accompagne de ces quatre heures il y
avait pascal et gimmi ils ont apporté
tomate est nécessaire pour réaliser les
pieds nous avons beaucoup travaillé pour
trouver la prédisposition des personnes
le bon cadrage la bonne lumière
expliquez-nous les différentes phases
alors le premier jour du tournage ça
consistait à filmer la scène de fête
il fallait recréer une ambiance festive
entre les dames c'était assez compliqué
à mettre en place au début certains
regarder la caméra d'être grillé cela
nous apporter cela nous a demandé un
effort de concentration
le deuxième jour de tournage étaient la
partie la plus technique en la matière
ont commencé à plier à cet accident mais
la place de marquer pour les tgv et les
différents éléments de la scène comme la
voiture accidentée
tous les ans au niveau maritime
sapeurs-pompiers et les tic en votre
coeur on a dû faire avec le temps la
pluie commençait à tomber
au final ça a fait un bond de la fumée
qui sortait du sol l'après midi on y est
allés au cimetière pour filmer le biais
d'une interview on était placé devant le
corbillard pour sortir le cercueil
le cortège de civils - avez-vous
participé à sotchi pas pour ma part
c'était une belle expérience conçue à la
base un passionné de photo et participer
à ce petit et des fiertés pour moi j'ai
pu prendre des photos tout au long des
différentes étapes du projet pour en
faire ce week end durant le tournage du
film j'ai pu avoir du matériel pour
réaliser des prises de vue en complément
de ceux de l'équipe de tournage et ces
scènes ont été inclus dans le prix final
et j'ai pu voir tout le travail de fond
pour réaliser un clip et partitions
mentalités comment s'est passé
l'enregistrement du slam dabo méthode
nous avons disposé un cadran en fonction
de la lumière ce lait et la scène de
l'accident port doit une prise de vue de
qualité
ensuite tous les talents se sont placés
devant la caméra pour king n'est pas de
décalage et qu'on puisse avoir toute la
scène de l'accident en vie par la suite
donc s'est entraîné plusieurs fois pour
ajuster notre voie c'est la musique la
vraie difficulté c'était de gérer nos
émotions et de fixer la caméra tout en
par les centristes comment avez-vous bhp
au montage du clip bas après le tournage
qui termine il a fallu réaliser un
montage vidéo avec les différentes
sciences mais pour cela on a eu l'aide
des professionnels mais à willy fontaine
et sa faim n'a réalisé le montage avec
l'aide du logiciel phoque studio come
stay a remis un format que j'ai suivi ce
logiciel matin quand même assez
compliqué sim a dû choisir différentes
sciences a jeté dans le clip que
monsieur willy fontaine avait réalisé
auparavant
malgé aussi d'écouter la musique et les
veaux la bande sonore pour pouvoir
ajuster images et le son qu'il n'y ait
pas de décalage défi
ensuite marc du maître 12 nous sur
chacun des ballons au niveau des slams
personnel voilà